in 2012 the Los Angeles County Museum of
Art took up a project called levitated
Mass where they chose to create a
large-scale public art sculpture that
consisted of a 340 ton Granite stone
that would appear to be levitating in
front of the museum this 680,000 lb
stone is 21 ft tall and was transported
106 mi from the Quarry and this is where
it gets amazing as this 340 ton Stone
had to have a custom trailer truck
constructed around it and get this the
trailer was 260 ft long 32 ft wide had
44 axles and
196 semi- Wheels we've of course all
heard of 18 wheelers well this thing has
11 times as many tires and to move this
Stone 106 miles it traveled 4 M an hour
took 11 nights and costed a whopping 10
million in fact this project was said to
be quote the largest operation of its
kind since the Egyptians built the
pyramids and it took a year of planning
a preparation to complete it from start
to finish so let me get this straight
this 340 ton stone is well under half
the weight of the two colasse of mnine
statues that were moved more than three
times the distance and this 340 ton
stone is virtually 1third the weight of
the 1,00 ton ramum statue which was
moved even further than this one see
this is is what I'm getting at we have
absolutely no clue how the Ancients move
stones of this
magnitude